the number of civilian owned guns around
the world is estimated at 650 million
and 270 million of those handguns rifles
shotguns machine guns and even
improvised craft guns belong to the
people of the United States there are 90
guns per hundred Americans giving the
country the honor of the highest gun
ownership rate in the world did you know
which country comes in second as far as
guns per person Yemen with a population
of 23 million there are 55 firearms per
hundred Yemenis but that's still almost
half as many guns as Americans even
though Yemen is a war-torn country with
extreme poverty and political
instability and while Yemen packs the
second highest amount of heat per person
India has the second largest number of
privately owned guns with an estimated
forty six million weapons followed by
China Germany and Pakistan what about
gun violence the United States is the
fifth in the world for numbers of
homicides by guns behind Venezuela
Mexico Colombia and Brazil on the other
end of the spectrum Japan has one of the
strictest gun laws in the world and also
one of the lowest murder rates in 2008
there were only 11 gun-related homicides
Switzerland however ranks high in gun
ownership and low and violent crime
about 0.5 homicides per hundred thousand
people that's less than 1% when compared
to the rest of the world the u.s. stands
alone for high gun ownership and high
gun violence despite being a well-off
country what's the missing link is that
a lack of gun laws or is it something
else but at the same time nearly half
the population believes laws covering
the sale of firearms should be made more
strict